hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing Professor
Horace Slughorn and his famed slug Club
a club which can best be described
through the wise words of Albus
Dumbledore Horace said Dumbledore
believing Harry with the responsibility
to say any of this likes his comfort he
also likes the company of the famous the
successful and the powerful he enjoys
the feeling that he influences these
people he has never wanted to occupy the
throne himself he prefers the back seat
more room to spread out you see he used
to hand-pick favorites at Hogwarts
sometimes for their ambition or their
brains sometimes for their charm or
their talent and he had an uncanny knack
for choosing those who would go on to
become outstanding in their various
Fields Horus formed a kind of Club of
his favorites with himself at the center
making introductions forging useful
contacts between members and always
reaping some kind of benefit in return
whether a free box of his favorite
crystallized pineapple or the chance to
recommend the next junior member of the
goblin liaison office but before we dive
into the club any further I think we
should first examine the man behind its
creation Horus Slughorn Professor Horace
eugenius flacus Slughorn was a pure
blood wizard born sometime in the late
1800s in his youth Slughorn attended
Hogwarts and was sorted into Slytherin
house
during his time at the school he was
said to be particularly skilled in the
art of potion making years later in 1931
the Slughorn returned to Hogwarts to
serve as potions master and head of
Southern house he remained in this
position for nearly five decades as far
as physical appearance is concerned
Slughorn was certainly hard to miss when
we first encounter him in the Half-Blood
Prince we met with a delightfully Larger
than Life Persona an enormously fat bald
man with a belly so meant that the
buttons on his waistcoat were
threatening to burst off in addition to
his rotund physique Slughorn was
described as having a shiny Pate
prominent Gooseberry colored eyes and an
enormous silver walrus-like mustache he
was also known to be particularly fond
of lavish old-fashioned clothes sporting
waistcoats with gold buttons during the
day and luxurious velvet smoking jackets
one at home but somehow slughorn's
personality still seemed to outshine his
over the top physical appearance first
and foremost Slughorn possessed a unique
ability to Captivate those around him
with his natural Charisma his Larger
than Life personality would draw people
in like moths to a mesmerizing flame
through his affable demeanor and
infectious enthusiasm he created an aura
of warmth that would make you feel
instantly at ease in his presence though
there was also a bit of an inexplicable
undertone of vanity
Harry wasn't sure whether he liked
Slughorn or not he supposed he had been
Pleasant in his way but he had also
seemed vain but there was also a lot
more to slow corn than meets the eye you
see beneath his jovial exterior lay an
exceedingly cunning mind with a sharp
intellect but perhaps like Hall's most
well-known trade was his talent for
identifying extraordinary potential in
his students interestingly it was the
same trait that led to slughorn's
undoing forcing him into retirement in
the year 1981. we see one student that
caught slakonzai went by the name of Tom
Riddle a boy that we later learned would
grow up to become none other than Lord
Voldemort during Riddle's time at school
Slughorn spent a lot of time mentoring
middle and on one fateful day riddle was
able to manipulate Slughorn into giving
him information about horcruxes
fearing that people would find out
slakon retired from his post at the
school however slackhorn made a
reappearance in 1996 when Dumbledore
dangled the prospect of teaching Harry
Potter in front of him the slug Club
Horace slughorn's slug Club was an out
of hours dining and Social Club made up
of his most well-liked and famous
students the club provided its members
with unique opportunities mentorship and
access to influential contacts opening
doors for their future successors its
Origins date backed when he first began
teaching at the school in 1931. you see
Slughorn had a Keen Eye to identify if
someone would go on to achieve greatness
in some capacity and would take great
pride in their accomplishments while we
are given some indication as to who is
actually in this club in the books and
films we aren't provided with a complete
list names are mentioned and in the film
adaptation slughorn's wall is shown
where he proudly displays the members of
his Club but we want to know more in the
beginning of the Half Blood Prince
Dumbledore instructs Harry to try and
become chosen by Slughorn I tell you all
this Dumbledore continued not to turn
you against Taurus or as we must now
call him Professor Slughorn but to put
you on your guard he will undoubtedly
try to collect to you Harry you would be
the jewel of his collection the boy who
lived or as they call you these days the
chosen one when Harry first meets
Slughorn Slughorn immediately mentions
the similarities between Harry and his
parents Slughorn then discusses Harry's
mother Lily and expresses that she was
one of his absolute favorites unable to
contain himself any longer Slughorn
directs Harry towards the shelf
featuring all of his favorites all mine
each and every one ex-students I mean
you recognize Barnabas cuff editor of
the daily Prophet always takes my owl
should I wish to register an opinion on
the news of the day gwenic Jones captain
of the holyhead harpies free tickets
whenever I want them of course I haven't
been to a match in some time ah yes
regulus black no doubt there is his
older brother Sirius died a few weeks
ago I taught the whole black family
except Sirius it's a shame a talented
boy I caught regulus when he came along
of course but I'd have liked the set the
way that slycorn discusses his students
makes it sound as though they are his
possessions however one thing is
undeniable all of them went to achieve
some sort of fame or success without
further Ado here is the full list of
slughorns favorites in alphabetical
order from slalcorn's first and second
tenure as potions Master Adrian Adrian
was a student in slycon's class in the
year 1978. during his first tenure as
potions Master Adrian was born in the
year 1960 and maintained a good
relationship with Cyclone after he
graduated from Hogwarts though Adrian
went on to become a successful
photographer for the daily Prophet
zlughorn always had higher expectations
for him
Abraxas Malfoy Abraxas Malfoy was a pure
blood wizard a father to Lucius Malfoy
and grandfather to Draco Malfoy Abraxas
ended up becoming a good friend of
slughorns a fact that Draco Malfoy later
tried to leverage when he would name
drop his grandfather in an attempt to
join the slug Club it's unconfirmed
whether abraxist was actually in the
slug club or if he was just friends with
Slughorn I imagine that they were
probably around the same age Ambrosius
Flume Ambrosius Flume was a British
Wizard and business owner Flume was the
proprietor of the popular honeydukes
sweet shop located in hogsmeade though
Flume ran the shop he was not the
original owner as the shop was first
opened in 1641. honeydukes is famous for
its Bertie Bots every flavor beans among
other things
Avery Avery was a pure blood wizard who
attended Hogwarts at the same time as
Tom Riddle he was part of Tom Riddle's
gang that would eventually go on to
become the first Death Eaters they were
known as the Knights of walpurgis Avery
was a student of Slytherin house and
it's actually pictured in the film
adaptation Barnabas cuff Barnabas cuff
was a pure blood wizard that became
editor-in-chief for the daily Prophet
cough was presumably the employer of
fellow slug Club member Adrian in order
to join the club it's likely that kaf
was either a an exceptional student or B
and came from a famous magical
background as like horn points carf out
to Harry first when Harry begins to
observe his wall of favorites you
recognize Barnabas cuff editor of the
daily Prophet always takes my owl should
I wish to register an opinion on the
news of the day Blaise zabini Blazer
Beanie was a pure blood wizard that
attended Hogwarts around the same time
as Harry Potter
he was a member of Southern house and
was on good terms with Draco Malfoy and
his gang Blaze was a quiet boy that
mostly kept to himself although on
various occasions he expressed his
extreme prejudice towards Muggles
mugglebones and blood traitors BC we see
the initials BC scribbled onto a
photograph that is on slughorn's wall of
favorites BC appears to be some sort of
mountain climber and is depicted on some
sort of a snowy mountain top it's
possible that BC may be Barty Crouch Jr
or Barty Crouch senior though it's
unlikely that it would have been the
former as slugcorn completely
disassociates himself from Death Eaters
Cormac mclagan McCormick mclagan is
Hermione's favorite not serious
McCormick mclagan is a British pure
blood Wizard and a member of the mclagan
family which Slughorn knew well in the
slug Club Slughorn and mclagan had the
following exchange now you cormic I
happen to know you see a lot of your
uncle Tiberius because he has a rather
Splendid picture of the two of you
hunting nogtails in I think Norfolk oh
yeah that was fun that was we went with
Bertie Higgs and Rufus grimga this was
before he became Minister obviously
Dalia F Dahlia f is pictured on
slughorn's wall in the film adaptation
of the Half-Blood Prince it's likely
that she was not pressing her as she has
shown wearing a full Viking Maiden
costume in the picture on his shelf it
has been speculated that her full name
is Dahlia Fleur Perry though that is not
confirmed Dirk Cresswell Dirk Creswell
is a mugglethorn wizard that became head
of the goblin liaison office in the
ministry of magic during the ministry
takeover by Lord Voldemort Creswell
attempted to hide his Heritage by
forging a family tree however he was
later found out and Creswell was
eventually murdered by snatchers while
on the Run Eldred warpel Eldred warpel
was a pure blood Wizard and slug Club
member that would go on to become a
successful writer Walpole is shown in
the film adaptation of the Half Blood
Prince at the Christmas dinner Walpole
was friends with a Vampire named
sanguini and wrote a book entitled Blood
Brothers my life amongst the vampires
floracaro floricaro was a British witch
and member of Slytherin house though it
is not explicitly stated I would imagine
that she is somehow related to Death
Eaters Electro and Amicus Caro it's
likely that flora and her sister Hestia
were members of the slug Club due to
their pureblood Heritage Jenny Weasley
Jenny Weasley was a pure blood witch and
member of the Weasley family the sister
to Bill Charlie Percy Fred Georgian Ron
Jenny would go on to achieve great
things eventually becoming a
professional quidditch player for the
holyhead harpies she also married Harry
Potter and the pair had three children
James Albus and Lily gwenig Jones guanig
Jones of the Welsh witch who began
attending Hogwarts in the year 1979.
gwenig is pictured on Silicon shelf in
the film adaptation of the Half-Blood
Prince after graduating from Hogwarts
gwenic would go on to become the captain
and beta of the Welsh all-female
Quidditch team the holyhead harpies
Harry Potter okay you might just know
this character I'll skip the
introduction but Harry easily became a
member of Cyclone's Club after allowing
himself to become collected he did this
by doing exceedingly well in slughorn's
potions class with the help of the
Half-Blood Prince's potion book however
with Harry's reputation it's likely that
Slughorn would have eventually collected
him regardless of how well he performed
in the class
Hermione Granger Hermione was a
muckleborn witch and member of the
famous Trio she was an exceptionally
gifted witch and by far the best student
of her year and for this reason it was
inevitable that she would be picked up
by Horace for his slug club though it is
particularly impressive as Horus was a
bit prejudiced towards mugglebones
Hermione would eventually go on to
become Minister for magic Hestia Caro
the sister of Flora Caro and another
member of the Cairo family like Flora
it's likely that she is somehow related
to Death Eaters Amicus and electrocaro
at the beginning of the battle of
Hogwarts Hestia and her sister were seen
departing to the dungeons Lestrange
Lestrange is another name that we hear
quite a bit the strange like Avery is
one of the original members of Tom
Riddle's gang the same gang that would
go on to become Death Eaters Lestrange
is shown in a flashback in the film
adaptation of the Half-Blood Prince it's
likely that Lestrange was the father of
rodolfus Lestrange who would later marry
Bellatrix
Lily Evans Lily Evans was a muggle-born
witch and Harry Potter's mother she was
an impressive witch with a particular
talent in potions making her one of
slughorn's favorite favorites when
Voldemort attempted to murder her in a
family she went on to cast the famous
sacrificial protection which saved
Harry's life and ended Voldemort for a
period of time Lucius Malfoy a bit of a
sleaze Bank Lucius Malfoy was a pure
blood wizard that came from the famous
Malfoy family he was the father of Draco
Malfoy and Son of Abraxas Malfoy who was
a friend of slughorns it is stated that
during lucius's time at school he was
exceptionally gifted at potions earning
the attention of Horus Slughorn though
Lucius was a loyal Death Eater for many
years him and his family eventually
defected from the Death Eaters Melinda
bobbin Melinda bobbin was a British
witch who attended Hogwarts at the same
time as the trio bobin's family owned a
large chain of apothecaries and for this
reason alone she was invited into the
slug Club
not not was a pure blood Wizard and one
of the earliest Death Eaters the knot
family were part of the Sacred 28 the 28
pureblood British families that was
still truly pure blood by the time the
1930s rolled around Knott was likely a
member of Tom Riddle's gang and was a
friend of Slughorn for many years
Slughorn would later cut ties with knot
as not would go on to do Unthinkable
things in the name of the Death Eaters
regulus black regular Spike was a pure
blood Wizard and member of the famous
black family he was the son of Orion
until Burger black and the younger
brother of Sirius Black regulus was a
member of Slytherin house and would go
on to become Seeker for their Quidditch
team in the film adaptation of
Half-Blood Prince sligon points out a
photo of him in regulus to Harry ah yes
regulus plaque no doubt there is his
older brother Sirius done a few weeks
ago I taught the whole black family
except Sirius it's a shame a talented
boy I got wrecked when he came along of
course but but I'd have liked the set
Severus Snape zebra Snape is a half
blood wizard potions Master defense
against a dark arts Professor hogwart's
Headmaster and to deathy to defect her
Snape was invited to join the slug Club
because of his obvious talent and the
Art of potion making while a student at
Hogwarts Snape assumed to the Alias the
Half-Blood Prince and wrote all sorts of
tips and tricks into his copy of
advanced potion making Harry would later
find Snape's copy of the book
Tom Riddle and Tom Riddle is also known
as the Dark Lord Voldemort riddle ones
like Harry One of slughorn's absolute
favorites while a student at Hogwarts
riddle was a very impressive student who
expressed an unparalleled ability to
learn there is one particular branch of
magic however that riddle may have
learned a little too much about it has
been expressed that Slughorn was
responsible for providing riddle with
information on horcrux's which were
instrumental in Voldemort's rise to
power unknown name slughorn's class of
67. though we don't know the name of
this slug Club member we know that
someone in slagon's class of 67 would go
on to become the minister of magical
Transportation Wendy slink hard the last
member of horace's slug Club is Wendy
slinkhard who was a British witch and
author in the film adaptation of the
Half Blood Prince the sling card is
shown in a photograph on slughorn's wall
it's likely that slinkhard is related to
Wilbert sling God who is the author of
defensive magical Theory a book that
teaches defensive magic in a secure
risk-free way and there you have it the
slug Club from its exclusive membership
to the invaluable opportunities it
provides this group is a highlight of
the Hogwarts experience but Beyond The
Prestige and networking possibilities
the slug Club ultimately holds a deeper
lesson as we see in slicorn's own
Journey the connection to be fostered
with those around us can shape our paths
and transform our perspectives the power
of mentorship guidance and genuine
connection cannot be overstated and it
is these elements that make the slight
Club not just a fascinating facet of the
magical world but also a reflection of
the importance of community in our own
lives and that's it for this video If
you enjoyed the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel also
be sure to check out the content on
Spotify as well as my second Channel
Harry Potter Theory X until next time
remember there can be no light without
the dark and so it is with magic myself
I always strive to live within the light